[Music]
hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango indie
movie guide where I give you my picks of
the smaller films that are out in
theaters and also playing on video on
demand this week let's start with a film
that you can see in theaters it's called
our United Kingdom directed by amma
asante I saw it at the Toronto
International Film Festival last year
this movie stars David O yellow oh and
Roseman Pike two incredible actors it's
about the king of Botswana who in 1947
was studying in London when he fell for
an English girl I will never achieve
anything with well if I give my heart
you choose to marry the leader of an
African nation you will be responsible
for the downfall of the British Empire
in Africa you choose a life of insults
and shame I know what you're asking what
it means yes this relationship had a
huge fall out including racism people in
England white people weren't happy with
it also Botswana won't happy either and
their relationship also had wider
political implications the thing that I
really love about this movie is that it
doesn't go down that emotional
manipulative soppy over-the-top road
that you may expect instead it focuses
on the complexity of the relationship
what it meant to everyone and it shows
these two characters slowly becoming
leaders and becoming stronger in
themselves with the relationship and
what they stand for over two decades of
preparing you to be arguing this is how
you're facing a white woman by your side
you're trying to tear us apart I love
David Oh yellow Oh he's made it a point
to work with a lot of female directors
so five out of his last six films
including a United Kingdom have been
directed by women and that is really
important because it's a struggle for
female direct
to get the job in the first place and so
to have someone who is so critically
regarded as David Oh yellow Oh lend
their support it really means a lot and
there is a moment in this film when his
character gets on stage and he makes
this amazing speech to his people and it
will give you chills because of the
strength the ferocity of his performance
and the emotion is all there to love my
wife
[Music]
that's in theaters this week but over a
video-on-demand you've got a couple of
choices firstly hacksaw bridge and
Manchester by the sea two films have
been nominated for the Best Picture
Oscar this year and now available to
watch on Fandango now so if you miss
them in theatres if you couldn't see
them if they weren't playing near you
definitely worth watching at home but I
want to bring your attention to two
films in particular first off the love
which this is one of my favorite Indies
of last year it's directed by written
the costumes and props and makeup and
everything done by a nabilla who is an
incredible director that has a very
unique sense of style you really feel
that when you watch the love which it's
all made to look like a 60s
sexploitation film what do men want just
a pretty woman to love and to take care
it's about as the title suggests a love
which a woman who decides to concoct
potions to make men fall in love with
her but they don't have quite the right
effect what is it we
what is it baby what a [ __ ] it's all
about being a woman and how scary that
can be when a female is in her power the
the fear of the feminine that exists and
also what it's like to be a woman it's
one of the most unique movies that I've
seen in a long time and it's one of
those films where I think Quentin
Tarantino or someone like that would
look at it and love it I hope that it
becomes a cult favorite you can check it
out right now
on video-on-demand to anything and one
more for you to watch at home on
Fandango now is nocturnal animals this
is a film that I think should have been
nominated for Best Picture it's directed
by Tom Ford very intricately woven multi
storyline tale all about love and
consumerism and what it's like to live
in this material world there's
essentially three different storylines
going on there's a me and the present
reading her book she's in a loveless
marriage with army hammer
she lives in this beautiful house that
has no warmth to it it's weird I've been
thinking about him a lot lately and then
recently he sent me this book that he's
written and it's violent and it's sad
and he titled it nocturnal animals and
he dedicated it to me then there's the
story within the story the book and what
that is telling it's a very tense
thrilling scary storyline I'm a Gemini
my favorite colors pale pink I like long
walks and kids and then you have the
pass where you see Amy Adams and Jake
Gyllenhaal characters as they were when
they first got into the relationship you
look beautiful as always it's a film
that definitely leaves you with a lot
more questions than answers and I know
that might be frustrating to some people
and the great thing about it being on
Fandango now is that you can watch it
again straight after because that's
definitely what I felt like too
once they finish the movie nobody gets
away with what she did to recap in
theaters go to see our United Kingdom
video on-demand you can watch hacks or
Ridge
you can watch Manchester by the sea you
can watch the love witch or you can see
nocturnal animals plenty of choices for
you and don't forget to tell me on
Twitter which been your favorite indie
movies you've seen lately any
recommendations for me to check out I
love to hear from you guys and you can
also comment below I'll see you next
week